[Musique]
imaginez un monde sans problème de
communication
un monde où tout le monde aurait un
super pouvoir celui de lire dans les
pensées des autres ça serait magique non
tenez monsieur j'ai écrit un mot sur
cette feuille de papier est ce que vous
avez une idée de ce que ça peut être non
non je pense qu'on peut l'appeler
revient fort parce que le mot non c'est
exactement ce que j'avais écrit merci
beaucoup
depuis toujours j'adore chercher à
comprendre comment les choses
fonctionnent alors imaginez mon bonheur
quand j'ai appris mes premiers tours de
magie et c'est vraiment par la suite en
évoluant dans cet univers dans ce monde
que j'ai découvert le vrai secret kichka
qui se cache derrière chacun de ces
tours ce secret c'est la communication
c'est vrai comment un magicien peut-il
vous amener à regarder exactement là où
il le souhaite
comment un mentaliste peut-il réussir à
influencer vos pensées ou prédire votre
comportement
une des réponses possibles serait qu'ils
détiennent tous les deux les clés les
clés des portes de votre cerveau et
justement aujourd'hui j'aimerais
partager ses clés avec vous j'aimerais
vous offrir quelques techniques et vous
révéler quelques secrets de mentalist
afin de mieux communiquer avant ça je
vous propose une petite expérience je
vais vous demander de vous lever à les
élever vous magnifique restait bien dans
votre siège
super fermez les yeux un instant faites
moi confiance je vais vous demander
maintenant d'imaginer une forme
géométrique simple une fois que c'est
fait concentrez-vous sur une couleur une
couleur facile quand ce fait vous pouvez
ouvrir les yeux je vois pas mal de
personnes qui ont déjà ouvert les yeux
je vais maintenant demandé à toutes les
personnes qui ont en tête un cercle de
s'asseoir pas mal je vais maintenant
demandé également aux personnes qui ont
en tête la couleur rouge de s'asseoir
également allez-y on peut voir comment
avec cette simple expérience on arrive
déjà deviner ce qui se trouve dans la
tête d'à peu près 75 % des personnes ici
présentes mais je vous rassure
l'idée c'est d'aller un petit peu plus
loin ce qui reste debout
ne vous inquiétez pas ça veut simplement
dire que vous pensez de manière
différente des autres
ça veut aussi dire qu'il ya quelques
psychopathes parmi vous mais pas
d'inquiétude je voudrais demander à
quelqu'un de me rejoindre sur scène par
exemple monsieur ici bonjour votre
prénom
philippe bourgault la pluie revient fort
merci beaucoup plient vous pouvez vous
rasseoir enchanté public vous allez bien
magnifique je vous propose de vous
mettre juste ici philippe en fait laissé
une petite expérience ensemble ça va
aller assez vite
philippe est ce que vous êtes familier
avec cet objet oui un jeu de cartes
exactement je vois que vous connaissez
les mots du jargon philippaerts jeu de
cartes c'est un peu mon objet préféré à
l'intérieur 52 personnalités tout
différente des phases des couleurs des
figures des lettres des chiffres et je
vous demandais philippe maintenant vous
allez en prendre une celle que vous
souhaitez magnifique vous la montrer à
tout le monde sauf à moins évidemment je
ne regarde pas le retour de la caméra
mais vous pouvez montré à la caméra là
bas c'est bon philippe je peux me
retourne et je vous remercie je voulais
emprunte un instant on va la perdre plus
ou moins vers le milieu ici vous êtes
droitier ou gaucher philippe pouvait
tendre la main droite pour moi et mes
telle autre par dessus afin de les
regarder les cartes super attendait bien
les bras sur terre ça se passe bien
magnifique
philippe j'ai une petite question est ce
que vous êtes habitué au bluff
magnifique ça va être plus facile pour
moi philippe l'idée ça va être d'aller
dans votre esprit pendant l'instant
d'aller dans votre cerveau tu veux
demander de vous concentrer tout d'abord
sur la couleur de votre carte d'accord
ça peut être rouge ou noir c'est très
facile mais répété leur en boucle dans
votre tête
ok je vous remercie maintenant que je
sais que c'est du rouge on est d'accord
ça peut être du coeur ou du carreau
merci beaucoup pour l'information
philippe je vous demande émanant de
répéter en boucle la valeur de votre
carte répéter la en boucle d'accord ça
peut être un as 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 à
lettres d'amour roi ok on va partir là
dessus je dois vous avouer que j'ai une
petite hésitation mais ça devrait être
pas mal
pour la première fois philippe votre
carte était rouge ou noir poésie à tout
le monde
rouge on est d'accord c'était du coeur
ou du carreau plutôt du carreau on était
bien parti et en termes de valeur on
était sûr pas loin du set
je pense qu'on peut appeler dire
philippe très fort parce que le set de
carros est exactement exactement ce que
j'avais trimestre merci à vous filer
merci beaucoup plus fiable je vous
propose de nous attarder maintenant sur
les détails de cette expérience pour
tenter de comprendre un petit peu mieux
comment fonctionne vraiment la
communication en fait on a l'habitude de
la voir comme un tout mais quand on y
regarde de plus près on se rend compte
qu'il y a trois axes et le premier axe
ce sont justement les canaux de
communication
il ya trois canaux et vous le vous les
connaissez tous vous les employés
quotidiennement
le premier c'est le verbal les mots que
nous employons pour nous exprimer
le deuxième le para verbal l'intonation
de voix qu'on utilise et le troisième
probablement le plus intéressant dans
notre cas c'est le non verbal le langage
corporel les gestes imaginez si j'étais
arrivé tout à l'heure sur scène de cette
manière
bonjour j'aimerais vous parler d'un
sujet très intéressant qui est la
communication
je pense que vous dormirez déjà
heureusement en fait quand on dit quand
on y regarde de plus près on voit que le
verbal est très intéressant pour
transmettre un message
mais le non verbal et le para verbal le
sont encore plus lorsqu'il s'agit
d'appuyer sur ce message d'influencé et
justement influencer les autres on peut
influencer les autres avec le non verbal
mais également s'influencer soi même les
études le prouvent
quand vous adopté par exemple une
position de force une position ouverte
avant un exercice oral vous avez
beaucoup plus de chances de succès
pourquoi ne pas laisser la prochaine
fois lors d'un entretien d'embauché
en fait ça s'explique très simplement
parce que vous booster votre confiance
en vous donc on comprend comment on
communique on sait que c'est important
de bien communiquer d'ailleurs c'est
probablement la compétence la plus
importante aujourd'hui
et pourtant pourtant on parle quand même
de 35 milliards de dollars de pertes
chaque année à cause de problèmes de
communication c'est énorme ça ne devrait
probablement pas arriver aujourd'hui et
c'est pour cette raison que j'aimerais
vous donner cinq techniques 5 secret du
mentaliste que nous utilisons dans nos
spectacles pour mieux vous bluffer pour
vous attirer dans notre univers et que
vous allez pouvoir utiliser pour
améliorer votre communication
la première c'est la première impression
on dit souvent qu'elle se réalise dans
les cinq premières secondes et c'est
vrai tout à l'heure quand je suis arrivé
sur scène
vous aviez déjà décidé avant même que je
commence à parler de manière totalement
inconsciente
si oui ou non vous alliez m'apprécier
j'espère que c'est le cas la deuxième
technique c'est le langage des autres
nous avons tous notre propre langage
nos propres expressions nos propres
gestes que nous faisons est d'ailleurs
ils se transmettent entre nous imaginez
l'impact que vous pouvez avoir
si vous adaptez votre message au langage
de votre interlocuteur typiquement on ne
va pas s'adresser de la même manière
dans une entreprise un créatif qui est
chargé l'innovation codirecteur du
département ventes qui est en place
depuis plus de dix ans maintenant la
troisième technique
c'est la synchronisation on a vu tout à
l'heure ce que ça donnait si on ne
synchroniser pas nos propres canaux
ensemble mais encore une fois imaginez
l'impact que vous pouvez avoir
si vous synchronisez votre trois canaux
sur ceux de votre interlocuteur la 4e
technique celle écoutent aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on à forte tendance à écouter
pour répondre et non pas pour comprendre
et c'est là où les leaders les bons
leaders excellent il écoute tout le
marché leurs clients leurs employés
et c'est là où on fait la différence
entre une personne qui sera capable de
résoudre un problème ou alors qu'il
l'identifiera même pas la cinquième et
dernière technique c'est ma préférée
c'est l'empathie nous sommes pas des
ordinateurs
nous ne sommes pas des algorithmes comme
on en a parlé tout à l'heure nous sommes
humains et nous avons tous des émotions
je pense qu'il faut pas avoir peur de
les utiliser de les montrer de les
partager
pour réussir pour réussir à toucher les
personnes à l'intérieur d'elle-même
d'ailleurs le marketing vous connaissez
probablement le storytelling en fait ce
qu'ils utilisent cette empathie et
aujourd'hui les études montrent qu on
achète plutôt un produit pour son
histoire que pour le produit lui-même
évidemment ces cinq techniques ne sont
absolument pas exhaustive
il y en a beaucoup d'autres qui sont
plus intéressantes les unes que les
autres mais je suis convaincu je suis
vraiment convaincu qu'avec ces cinq
techniques si vous allez déjà pouvoir
améliorer votre communication
mais attention l'améliorer pas être
parfait on ne peut pas être parfait dans
beaucoup de choses je pense un époux roë
et encore moins en communication et
c'est là le deuxième axe c'est celui de
la perception
on peut adapter son message améliorer
son message mais c'est toujours
l'interlocuteur la personne halak à
laquelle on l'adresse qui va le recevoir
et ce message il va passer dans notre
cerveau il va être traité à travers des
filtres des filtres y sont par exemple
des expériences nos croyances ou encore
le contexte en prenant deux contextes je
vous propose une autre petite expérience
bonjour monsieur enchanté votre prénom
jérôme je vous propose de me rejoindre
sur scène on peut l'applaudir bien fort
enchanté jérôme je vous propose de
rester juste ici c'est parfait
jérôme g j'ai avec moi quelqu'un de
génial quelqu'un qui m'inspire beaucoup
vous le connaissez tous j'en suis sûr
c'est un des plus grands détectives au
monde il s'appelle sherlock holmes celui
d'arthur conan doyle en tout cas j'aime
j'ai une petite question pour vous
combien de pages se trouve dans ce livre
à peu près vous pouvez le dire bien sûr
alesi 202 exactement 202 exactement
jérôme je vous propose quelque chose on
va se mettre dos à dos si ça ne vous
dérange pas on va se mettre dos à dos
comme ça vous êtes sûr que je ne peux
pas tricher
s'ils essayent de tricher vous allez
sentir vous allez sentir modo on de
bouger vous allez voir que j'essaie de
regarder on est bien d'accord j'ai re
super jérôme je vous propose d'ouvrir le
livre à la page que vous souhaitez c'est
fait magnifique
est ce que vous pouvez me donner le
numéro de la page à laquelle vous l'avez
ouvert
pardon excusez moi page 100 pages page
110 ok mais est ce que vous voulez
changer non concentrez vous sur la page
110 jérôme j'ai l'impression qu'à la
page 110 on parle beaucoup moins
aujourd'hui c'est la preuve d'une
rétrogration morale qui ajouté au déclin
de sa fortune semblent indiquer quelques
vices est ce que c'est de ça dont on
parle à la page 118 rom je pense qu'on
peut la pluie revient fort merci
beaucoup 0 félicitations à vous merci
beaucoup
oui c'est beau est-ce que vous avez une
idée de comment j'ai fait exactement je
n'ai pas appris tout par coeur je vous
donne un indice vraiment sur la manière
dont ça fonctionne oui alors non je sais
je re mi a pas de souci il ya une petite
différence entre votre livre est le mien
on montre à tout le monde
en réalité jérôme mon livre à moi il est
entièrement entièrement entièrement
blanc je pense qu'on peut appeler un
bien fort merci à vous jérôme
merci à vous pourquoi et comment votre
cerveau s'est il trompé
et c'est là le troisième et dernier axe
lax des heuristiques une heuristique
c'est un mot un petit peu compliquée
dont on n'a pas l'habitude pour dire
quelque chose de très simple en fait une
ristic c'est un raccourci un raccourci
que notre cerveau a appris de manière
support de totalement inconsciemment ou
non et qu'ils utilisent pour penser plus
rapidement pour réagir rapidement
typiquement ici vous avez vu un livre
dans ma main et je suppose que vous en
avez déduit que ce livre était
exactement le même que celui de jérôme
c'est là que votre cerveau vous a trompé
puisque comme vous l'avez vu il était
complètement blanc autre chose vous avez
vu que je portais des lunettes et votre
cerveau vous a également appris que
l'une est égale problèmes de vue et en
réalité je n'ai pas de problèmes de vue
d'ailleurs ses lunettes n'ont même pas
de verre les holistique c'est donc très
bien mais comme nous venons de le voir
ça mène à des erreurs quelques erreurs
qu'on appelle des billets j'ai utilisé
aujourd'hui plusieurs biais plusieurs
biais par exemple la première expérience
j'ai utilisé ce qu'on appelle l'illusion
de corrélation encore une fois c'est un
terme très compliqué mais est ce que
quand je claquer des doigts
cela avait un réel impact sur la suite
du tour où était ce juste place et là un
subterfuge place est là pour vous
bluffez autre chose jérôme hess qui est
utilisé avec jérôme une
une autre un autre biais une autre
illusion l'illusion du choix at il
vraiment ouvert le livre où il le
désirait où ai je réussi d'une manière
ou de nouilles ou d'une autre à
l'influencé l'évier on ne peut pas y
échapper
c'est clair mais on peut en faire deux
choses quand on en a conscience
la première c'est les utiliser c'est un
peu ce que je viens de faire ici
aujourd'hui pour essayer de vous bluffez
de vous divertir et la deuxième c'est
tenter de les identifier
pour les éviter et ça serait là l'idée
plutôt dans la vie quotidienne ou dans
l'entreprise
finalement je pense qu'on peut dire
qu'un magicien qu un mentaliste utilise
des techniques très rationnel pour vous
faire croire à des choses qu'ils sont
beaucoup et ses techniques
vous pouvez les utiliser pour améliorer
votre communication
même si comme nous l'avons vu la manière
dont le cerveau fonctionne fait qu'il
sera toujours impossible de communiquer
parfaitement
il reste peut-être une dernière question
à se poser est ce que je triche est sain
dont celle ci à votre imaginaire à votre
imagination
mais avouez quand même que s'il n'y a
pas de truc c'est magique
et s'il y en a un c'est encore plus fort
merci
[Musique]